FEMA administrator Brock long is with us
from the agency's National Response
Coordination Center in Washington for an
interview you'll see only on CBS this
morning
administrator long good morning good
morning John how are you very well thank
you let's talk about Hawaii it's been 25
years since they've faced something like
this what are the unique challenges that
they face in are they ready so that's a
great question obviously being an island
jurisdiction several thousand miles from
the continental United States can can
make this disaster a very complex one
but what's different is is that I
believe that the infrastructure that
Hawaii has done a great job of
maintaining their infrastructure it's a
little more mitigated than what we've
seen in some of the other island
territories we've established great
communication and we've been you know
really focused on helping the island
prepare for any health and safety issues
that that we're going to see as the
initial impact start to push through and
then we pre position resources and and
really try to engage our private sector
partners as the storm passes through if
there's any impact to energy
communications transportation or the
health and medical system we feel like
we're ready to go to support the
governor in his efforts to respond and
recover administrate along FEMA is still
facing a great deal of criticism for how
your team responded to Hurricane Maria
in Puerto Rico what did you learn that
makes this response different now if for
Hawaii sure so well first of all
disaster preparedness mitigation
response and recovery is a team effort
it takes the whole community what work a
lot went really well last year if you
look at Texas for example you had
anything from neighbor helping neighbor
which is incredibly important in the
disaster response and recovery piece all
the way to the federal government
clearly understanding how to support the
state with their gaps in the in the
ability to respond and recover and
that's the model that we strive for all
disaster response and recovery should be
locally executed state managed and
federally supported and so we're doing a
lot of work to redesign plans pre-event
contracts not just our pre-event
contracts to support response and
recovery but setting up contracts at all
levels of government to make sure that
we have a full fully capable baseline at
all levels of government to be able to
attack these types of
disaster events Minister Brock long we
appreciate your time thank you so much
thank you